so these are the guys that just
conquered afghanistan take a look at
this
dude
how much are these guys benching
40 pounds maybe at most
[Music]
and these people just conquered
afghanistan in two days
okay so joe biden uh addressed the
public yesterday and uh gave a pretty
short speech about the situation in
afghanistan took no questions
hurried off the state well hurried as
much as he can possibly heard he kind of
shuffled off the stage afterwards took
no questions
from the press
we know that if this was if this was
trump
in a similar situation and giving a
speech
even people who hate trump would have to
acknowledge that he would have sat there
for an hour
or stood there rather taking
questions from the press
every single question
hostile to him but he would he would
have stood there
reveling in it taking the questions but
joe biden can't take any hostile
questions he's off the stage
um
the speech itself has been roundly
panned by
really everyone on all sides
and that's pretty rare that a speech
given by a politician is going to be
panned by both sides especially when
it's a democrat politician the media
hated it for the most part some
exceptions uh certainly everyone on the
right hated it
let's play a quick clip of uh the speech
just to get the kind of the flavor of it
here it is
i've argued for many years that our
mission should be narrowly focused on
counter-terrorism not
counterinsurgency or nation-building so
what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement in afghanistan now
was the right decision american troops
cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
uh i i have to tell you i feel dirty
listening to abide in speech and
agreeing with anything he says
but
i did in fact agree with those clips
there i agreed with pretty much all of
that
now
that doesn't make it a good speech okay
because for one thing in terms of
delivery you could tell that he could
barely he barely knows what he's saying
uh you could see it in his eyes you
could tell in the way he's delivering it
he's he's reading the words that it's
not registering in his brain
so that's that's a pretty big problem
um and also it was an excuse-making
speech and it it did not deal with the
real issue and the thing that has caused
uh and precipitated most of the
criticism
which is the the way that the the
withdrawal was handled the way that the
pull out was handled
he didn't he just glossed right over
that
common political technique also pretty
smart political technique
to talk about the thing you know you're
going to talk about the thing that you
want to talk about you're going to frame
it the way you want to frame it you're
not going to talk about what your
critics are talking about
but um
we can't really call so it was it it
may or may not have been a politically
smart speech i guess we can't even call
it that because it was panned by
everybody
um there's probably no speech he could
have
given
that would have changed much of anything
for him politically
but he did avoid talking about the main
thing which is how the pull-out was
handled
and why it was handled that way
instead he's talking about why we needed
to leave
as far as that goes
the reasons that he gives
putting the the pull out to the side
the reason that he gives for leaving
that i agree with
and you know what if he had given that
exact speech six months ago and in fact
he did give almost that exact speech six
months ago when he was laying out why we
had to leave and that's i agree with it
the problem is that he's giving it again
now when that's not really the issue the
issue is the manner the manner of
leaving
but even with that acknowledged um
he he is it is true
that the afghan military gave up
the entire afghan government fled the
country
he should have known that that was going
to happen
i think he did know or at least the
people really running our government
knew that it was going to happen
should have planned for that should have
taken that into consideration
made sure that we could evacuate all of
our people beforehand before all of that
happened
but there's no but there's no getting
around the fact that they did in fact
flee the country and the afghan military
gave up
and i i don't see how
you can put all the blame on on biden
that you want fine by me
um
but i don't see how
the afghan military
escapes all blame the way people are
talking about them it's like they're a
bunch of infants like they're toddlers
oh poor afghan military we can't expect
anything from them really we can't
300 300 000 of them supposedly
trained and equipped for 20 years
we abandoned them we bet 20 years later
we abandoned them 20 years later
that's what you call abandonment
when you're left to defend your own
country after 20 years abandoned
now if you want to talk about abandoning
our own people on the ground and not
having a
a
plan in place to get them out yeah
there's abandonment
heads should roll over that there should
be resignations over that
there should be there should be prison
sentences over that
but if you're gonna sit here and tell me
that the afghan military was abandoned
it's their country what do you mean
abandoned to their own country
if you're a military and you can't
defend your own nation after 20 years of
being trained
then whose fault is that
and i don't want to hear anything about
oh well they didn't have air support
yeah that's the point we're leaving take
care of yourself now
did the taliban have air support
well they didn't have the intelligence
on the ground how much intelligence does
the taliban have
these this sev this gang of
seventh century
savage scumbags
are they flying in there with jets
and you got you got you got a quarter
million of you and you just leave you
don't even try
even if i were to say that they're
they're put in a difficult situation
because the our military isn't there to
guide them and help them
fine it's a difficult spot so you don't
even try then you don't even try
is what we're being told
that's what so if you're if you're in
the military you're putting a tough spot
don't even try
give in to forces that you outnumber
three or four to one
hey can we play this here here's the
taliban by the way after they took over
the presidential palace let's play this
here's them uh they're in a gym checking
out some of the gym equipment
there they are
so these are the guys that just
conquered afghanistan take a look at
this
how much are these guys benching
40 pounds maybe at most
[Music]
that dude
he's trying to
he has no idea well he's never used any
kind of
gym equipment in his life clearly
all right that guy was bicep curling
about about 15 pounds
and these these are the dudes there was
there was another video of them taken
over an amusement park and they're like
applying on the bumper cars
and these people just conquered
afghanistan in two days
can't even say they conquered because
there was no there was no fight
it wasn't even a surrender it was just
like yeah you can have it
there you go country's yours
i don't i don't buy that i i don't i
don't buy absolving
you you are duty bound to defend your
own country that's why you're in the
military
absolving them of blame give me a break
come on
well i hope you enjoyed that clip for
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content